das bild gestern berichtet hat ist heute
wahr geworden so kann man es sagen am 19
in dem fall am dienstag findet die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz stadt und
das ist insofern überraschend als dass
diese ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wo es
geschichte von corona immer um die
verlängerung verschärfung oder
lockerungen von maßnahmen ging
eigentlich erst am 25 januar stattfinden
sollte und wenn man sich die vergangenen
tage anschaut dann war das wie bei
corona auch in der vergangenheit schon
so ein polit krimi in hinterzimmern in
telefonaten in schalten was dort
passiert ist wir wissen zum beispiel von
dieser kurve die du am anfang gezeigt
hast diese irland kurve das dass die
kurve ist die die kanzlerin immer in
jeder schalter mit allen ministern
erwähnt hat das ist die angst kurve und
ein teilnehmer aus den
kabinettssitzungen hat zu mir gesagt es
herrscht die blanke angst in der
regierung vor einer entwicklung wie in
irland nämlich vor einer mutation und in
dem fall dass ich eben corona viel
schneller ausbreitet als wir das von der
ersten version des virus sozusagen
kennen und das ist das was die kanzlerin
so beschäftigt und das ist deshalb warum
sie verschärfen will bild hat gestern
exklusiv als erstes medium in
deutschland darüber berichtet dass es
nicht nur eine verlängerung sondern
möglicherweise auch verschärfung geben
soll und was ist mir darüber wer hat
sich jetzt gestern mit wem beraten
das ist eigentlich beriet sich jeder die
ganze zeit muss man sagen und das
spannende daran ist das passiert nicht
einfach so am rande einer
kabinettssitzung wie man sich das
vielleicht vorstellt sondern das
funktioniert bis in die nacht in sitzung
wir kennen die bilder von jens spahn und
der kanzlerin am montag wo sie vier
stunden lang im kanzleramt war nach
mitternacht erst raus kam mit sehr
ernsten betriebenen minen eigentlich
hätte man da schon lesen können was da
gerade im hintergrund passiert und wir
bei bild haben dann angefangen und
ohnehin natürlich die ganze zeit im
gespräch mit den beteiligten mit den
ministern aber zu recherchieren und dann
haben wir erfahren dass am anfang der
woche ist bereits schalten gab ein ganz
enger kreis ganz kleiner kreis die
kanzlerin hatte große sorge dass
sozusagen ihre
ihre vorstellung war zu früh raus kommen
könnten es gab dann auch eine schalte
der kanzlerin mit dem vizekanzler und
helge braun also sie hat den kreis sehr
sehr eng gezogen und da wurde das das
erste mal angedeutet dass die kanzlerin
eine verlängerung der maßnahmen wie wir
sie jetzt kennen über den 31 januar
hinaus schon will und dass sie auch
verschärfungen möchte und da müssen wir
vielleicht einmal kurz konkret werden
da geht es um ganz verschiedene dinge
die kanzlerin in diesen sitzungen in
diesem video konferenzen in den schalten
sagt sie immer wieder zu teilen den mann
es sind zu viele menschen in deutschland
unterwegs sie sagt wenn sie sozusagen
morgens zur arbeit fährt so muss man
sich das vorstellen die kanzlerin wohnt
in berlin mitte aber natürlich sieht sie
auch was auf der friedrichstraße los ist
wenn sie auf dem weg zum kanzleramt sind
wie viele leute sozusagen auf dem weg
zur arbeit sind und sie vergleicht das
ganze immer wieder mit der situation im
märz/april wo wir den ersten lockdown
haben und ich glaube jeder der morgens
zur arbeit fährt und das damit
vergleicht wie es sozusagen am anfang im
frühjahr gewesen es sieht dass mehr
leute auf der straße sind und die
kanzlerin sagt das muss dringend weniger
werden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren